so Isis so you know last week we did a
video and I said everyone's talking
about Isis now we were a day or two
ahead of the thing they are releasing
these insane videos of beheadings and
massacres and just shooting people in
the streets and all this terrible stuff
and we showed one of them last week and
now we actually found a worse one so I'm
just warning you
this is beyond graphic and horrible so
you are warned okay so that was Isis
beheading a Syrian soldier in Syria not
in Iraq they are in Iraq and Syria and I
think it's important to show this stuff
because the mainstream media isn't
showing it partly just because it's so
graphic uh but also this is spreading
this is getting worse every day I feel
like we don't even know how to talk
about this because it's that horrific
and we've never dealt with anything of
that level people say really bad things
about Isis but they did return that
severed head to its rightful body at the
end of that video so you know just hear
the great sandal make sure we put it all
in context uh yeah I think it's
important show it to uh I don't I think
we should be careful a little bit not I
think you should show and we should talk
about it but but I mean Iraq and Syria
for the last few years I mean it's not
the first beheading I don't know whether
these guys are doing it a ton more that
was happening in Iraq when you know more
than a hundred thousand civilians were
killed during the war right we do it we
have rules if you shoot you know ten
thousand people some they somehow think
that's not that bad but if we see a
hundred people decapitated then it's
worse but I guess it's the optics of it
well one I'm think that guy was already
dead I'm pretty sure so I don't think it
bothered him that much
yeah so yeah it gets back to this thing
of war like what school what's that cool
like somehow that's worse then you they
already killed them so I don't I
understand you're supposed to have
reverence for a body and all that stuff
which I don't know how much I believe in
and it's in and for real right and
because it's you it just makes people
crazier right all we have to protect
this sacred body the dead the guys that
already it doesn't really matter and III
you know yeah they wouldn't beheading
people they used to have fur guillotines
and for civil societies so this is not
that to me it's like it's gruesome to
look at but you know it's not any more
gruesome than the rest of the war that
40,000 people on the top of a mountain
that they're trying to kill that they're
not they don't even have shoes or water
they're dying from first right so now we
are down doing some strikes and we
apparently drop some food in someone yes
so uh you know I I'm getting that that
thing that people had when during the
Syria thing you know some people wanted
leather we gotta go back I'm getting
that right even though I'm totally
against that stuff yeah like I had a I
was walking my dog today I was like I
would like to go shoot some Isis cat so
that's the thing about this will for
what one they stopped doing the
guillotine in part because it was too
hard to cut somebody's head off even
with the guillotine which that video
shows it's not easy which is why the
ultimately stop just from a manpower
point of view it's just a lot of work uh
for very little reward but the reward
that they have now is terror yeah it
strikes terror into people and of course
what this builds the danger of what this
builds and what their hope you know they
what they would like to accomplish I
suspect if they're this sophisticated
about it is that you know John Kerry and
the Foreign Minister of Australia get on
television and they talk about the
picture of the boy with the sever well
let's show that out so like in that
picture does nothing like everybody's
grotesque group let you see the real
picture this means nothing right so this
is the seven-year-old son of a guy named
Khalid Shalhoub who is a convicted
australian terrorist who left Australia
to go fight for Isis and he brought his
kid so yeah we'd I do the only image we
could find was with the yeah try I try
to find the real one I couldn't
turns out that that guy's dad is
schizophrenic case yeah and he's been in
hospitals and he's been and and somebody
they treated him and they're like any
secured is it he's a comedian yeah he's
just the comedian occasions you know
issues yeah so what what what worries me
and as it worries me but I'm certain it
will happen is that you get John Kerry
in the Foreign Minister of Australia
talking about how hideous this is
everybody's talking about it is this is
at some point someone some Western
country will capture some Isis guys
right and we will think these are the
guys we sauce on this guy's head off
right and this kid made his kid hold a
severed head John Kerry was revolted by
right well we're not gonna want to give
that guy a trial we're not gonna care
how long we lock that guy up without
giving him a trial and throw them away
in a Cell or execute him and never let
him see a judge you know this week Ramzi
bin al-shibh
one of the orchestrators of the 9/11
attack which we who we caught in 2002 he
just had his trial separated from the
other guys it's 2014 these guys haven't
gone in front of a judge yet for their
formal trial and the prosecuting saying
that's outrageous how can you separate
this trial when it seems like there's
real evidence that the torture that we
did to Ben I'll she has made him insane
and he's not competent to assist in his
own defense we don't care we don't care
because they killed 3,000 people and the
system that we had and the structure of
justice is supposed to apply to everyone
but these guys are gonna make us once
again shrug our shoulders and abandon
any sort of rule of law because we're
gonna feel like these guys when they
sawed off that Syrian soldiers head they
lost the right to be treated civilly and
the war machine will continue are we
really dealing with saying that we've
never dealt with in that regard like
they want us to play on our worst parts
of ourselves that seems obvious they
want war you know you mean it's like
with with Hamas and they want dead
civilians on both sides so then they
force Israel to shoot and then Israel
does something they don't want to do and
then you just get more dead people so
are we and we're really in like a
culture
or right now right across the world I
would disagree with that framing but I I
don't remember your question was that
question that let's move on to so Isis
again is there basically that's about
Isis right so this just goes again the
hubris of American foreign policy to
think that somehow we're gonna go fix
the Middle East right so we're gonna go
and we're gonna bring democracy to the
people of Iraq with their purple fingers
they [ __ ] voted so like that was some
kind of a thing so what everybody said
would happen exactly happened there's a
power vacuum and the worst of the worst
so we made the system twenty five
billion dollars twenty five billion
dollars we spent training the Iraqi army
700 of those Isis guys chased thirty
five thousand Iraqi army guys with this
drop the uniforms eleven by the way
basis is now using our stop you think
they're using our uh artillery in right
because they just stole it
John McCain would probably say we gotta
give the arms to someone else that's
only gonna catch Democrats and
Republicans telling Barack Obama that we
made a huge mistake by that by not
giving arms to Syrian moderates as if we
could figure out who they were and that
now Isis is fill the power vacuum that
we abandoned I mean we need the only
legitimate criticism that you can give
to the administration in Syria to me is
well we did nothing in this happened but
you cannot extrapolate that this
happened because we did not like we
would did something it might have been
worse but we don't or or more likely
nothing like it would have it would have
very lot more us arms there right and
we'd be essentially in the same
situation but that we could have
prevented it by funding these guys I
think is is silly and we what we and the
fact of the matter is we absolutely
can't possibly know right and we fund
guys and then we fund the guys that come
after them and when the Syria thing was
happening I remember me and you were the
two that were completely against the war
I mean think about it we they wanted to
bomb Assad well then that would have
just now strengthened Isis I so
everything we do is kind of backwards so
it goes to my last question on this was
this sort of the perfect storm of we had
the war that was made up the original
the Iraq war that george w bush it's
obviously his in Cheney's fall but then
Obama was sort of the perfect president
to now screw it up even further by
completely getting us out
you know me like everyone wanted out but
I just we had a bad president that got
us in and then this guy that just felt
like well it's not ours to take care of
anymore so it was sort of perfect storm
of well this is what's gonna happen I
don't know III don't I don't agree with
that I don't I think one of the good
things that he's done is get us out I
mean I I don't know what the alternative
I know the alternative is either and so
at some point you have to leave I mean I
don't know what's long enough yeah eight
years strikes me is probably long enough
three years longer than World War two
strikes me is long enough um and I don't
know what we could have done and what
you think if we'd spent another 7
billion dollars and train those guys for
another year they do they have been
better yeah I think they didn't want to
fight so we just don't know what we're
doing that sort of fills out about that
David I don't understand why like so
we're Saudi Arabia you know why don't
why aren't they what don't they have a
problem with Isis or are they cool with
Isis right god they gotta have a problem
with Isis is a threat Saudi Arabia is
part of the California but Egypt you
know what about like why do we have to
do and we have to do what Saudi Arabia
there's other countries George which is
what sama bin Laden said about when we
went into Kuwait
the United States went into the Kuwait
he's like you know why didn't we take
care of this why we got to ask the
infidels to come over and take care of
this and that's what bad exactly why
didn't Saudi Arabia take care of Kuwait
white even think [ __ ] do that why did
we have to go so that's what I don't get
like what are the other Arab oil-rich
countries doing with all their money and
weaponry right so let's see what happens
one thing that Isis has done well is
they're paying guys who they're paying
poor young men to fight are they capable
of governing
I doubt it no I doubt it you know you
know and and we still don't know how
many guys there are how many are we
talking about so what was the UN to like
words why don't they why don't wasn't
there a force that can go in and save
these people why I don't think we have a
force I think you wouldn't know I know
that but I don't think it exists anymore
I think it's does something or nobody
does anything and I don't know that
either one's any better
[Music]